>> What Kofi Annan, the former Secretary General
of the UN, was saying is very pertinent.
We are here to discuss the global issues including
the global crisis.
And specifically, some of us are here to make
our contributions as to
see different developments in Africa, our
continent, and how it is
afflicted by these crisis.
In relation to our development, within education
and environment and
agriculture, and the other things, infrastructure,
investment and how Africa problem gets integrated
in this world where
most of the systems, the economic and others,
are also integrated.
So we will be making our contributions in
the discussions that are
going on.